foreign
this is a National Geographic map of the
world
we're in a basement office at National
Geographic headquarters and Karen Berry
is standing in front of a huge map that
stretches from floor to ceiling
like a military General she points out
explorers deployed all over the planet
and the unique hazards each might face
in that part of the world I have
Travelers in the Congo right here on the
border and I'm very concerned about this
and I want to know exactly where they
were because over here just across the
border we've got an ebola outbreak
Karen is the nurse here at National
Geographic and her full-time job is
making sure our explorers photographers
writers and all kinds of Travelers are
safe
so I might have you know
20 to 50 Travelers in the field at any
given time right it's a lot that's a lot
of people to keep track of it has a lot
to keep track of I remember a story
someone was out in the Pacific and a
volcano blew up and
I emailed that I said how are you doing
out there he said I didn't know anybody
knew where I was I'm good
when something goes wrong she's on speed
dial for every Explorer
probably her most famous customer is
Brady Barr a biologist who hosted a show
on National Geographic Wild called
Dangerous encounters you know over the
years that Geographic I broke my right
leg broken right leg broken right arm
broken right wrist I lost my right index
finger
um when you lost your index finger yeah
it's still there it's they put it back
on Croc bite snake bite monkey bite
brain worms that was that that was my
closest call was was the brain worms I
picked those up in Cambodia
[Music]
at large at National Geographic magazine
and you're listening to overheard a show
where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at Nat Geo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world this week when
you're in National Geographic Explorer
and you've got an assignment to go
diving in say the Amazon River or to
hike up a remote volcano who's your
first call
that would be Karen Berry our resident
nurse we'll hear how she prepares people
for extreme assignments all over the
planet where there is no Medical Aid and
will meet her most injury-prone patient
herpetologist and alligator Wrangler
Brady Barr that's coming up right after
the break
[Music]
fuel your curiosity with a free
one-month trial subscription to Nat Geo
digital you'll have unlimited access on
any device anywhere ad-free with our app
that lets you download stories to read
offline explore every page ever
published with a century of digital
archives at your fingertips check it all
out for free at Nat geo.com Explore More
a lot of the stories we pursue at
National Geographic are inherently
dangerous things like photographing
wildfires climbing remote peaks in the
Himalayas or visiting countries with
diseases like malaria and Ebola
Karen Berry has helped our explorers
survive it all hi I'm Karen Berry and
I'm the nurse manager of National
Geographic Society okay and how long
have you been here Karen I feel like
you've always been here at least in my
in my tenure I have been here for 17
years wow 17 years yeah okay so what was
your first day at National Geographic
like the one thing I remember that
really stands out was
the emergency preparedness team came to
talk to us about what would happen in
the event of a fire I almost died in a
fire so that meant a lot to me really
yes wait a minute you almost died in a
fire and nursing school
I was um in a room next to where the
fire originated someone had left an iron
plugged in it was an old iron caught the
the top of the ironing board which
caught the drapes and the room went up
and it was I had just completed finals
and so I had been up the entire night
before
so I was out cold sleeping on the bed
and my roommate came in to try and save
me and she said she kept calling my name
but I was in such a deep sleep
she grabbed me by the ankles and
literally pulled me off the bed and I
hit the ground and that's when I woke up
the room was full of black smoke
and I had to crawl out and it was just
very frightening and so here all these
nurses were standing in their pajamas
out in the parking lot and the whole
room was going up in flames
but it left me you know with the fear of
fire and on that very first day I
remember them talking about what would
happen in the event of a fire
I eventually joined that emergency
preparedness team as part of National
Geographic and I look at it with a very
critical eye because of what happened to
me hearing your background as a nurse at
a hospital
that sounds like a very Hands-On like
here's the problem it's right in front
of me I I can put my hands on it and fix
it but what you do here is sort of
prepare people to fix their own problems
yes that's that's exactly right but does
that feel weird like you're kind of far
removed so how do you how do you adjust
to that so nurses are teachers my plan
of care is to keep them well and healthy
while they're working and in the field
and I measure that by the the healthy
returning traveler that comes back it's
it's good to have a nurse on your staff
you know a lot of the assignments that
we send people to go do are just risky
by the nature of what they're doing you
know we're sending people to the Arctic
we're sending people up high mountains
you know we're singing well we just sent
a crew into the Sandwich Islands going
to hike up a volcano you know in the
middle of nowhere
yeah right so I mean this is just not
safe stuff by definition addition how do
you bring some level of of safety to
that what I do is I actually put myself
in their place
what what is going to happen to to me if
I'm in that exact position
you could have 15 foot waves they were
going to be in some pretty rough ocean
conditions
and then they're hiking up this ice
field right so what would happen if they
fell onto hard ice they could have
concussions they could have deep wind
lacerations so I sent them out with
bleed control kits all right and then
they were up at the top of this volcano
Gathering gas samples and Volcanic
samples so what could happen there there
could be a splash so I sent them out
with a massive burn kit
we're asking people to do these really
difficult things
and sometimes you know you get into a
situation where you kind of feel like
you got to push through the goal is just
up ahead or you need to climb just a
little higher how how do you tell
you know an Explorer or where to find
that line right so you know if they are
in a malarious area and they've got a
wicked headache and they've got fever
and shaking chills
I'm telling them game over get out
malaria will kill you very quickly and
we want you alive
but I will talk to them about the signs
and symptoms of any of the diseases that
are risk and and when to step back and
say you know your life is really in
danger stop have you ever had to tell
somebody look this is just too dangerous
an assignment don't don't do this this
is just not gonna fly from a medical
point of view
um so that happened once during coved
once in 17 years because uh see
my job is not to tell them it's a no-go
but there was one assignment that that
happened and I just said I'm not going
to allow it I'm putting my foot down
you're not going this was at the start
of coven and there was a whole group of
employees that wanted they were ready to
hop on a plane and go to Southeast Asia
borders were closing I was trying to get
people out of room and bring them home
we had people in South Africa
and I just said you're not going
how could you ever fathom a global
pandemic this large
you know and and the effects that it had
on the world but that was the one time I
just said absolutely not you're not
going yeah right right what's the most
dangerous activity you think we send
people to do and how do you prepare for
that I think
um the mega transits that we've done
like the okanwanga Delta project that
was incredibly so they're actually like
basically crossing the entire thing on
the boat or foot or whatever it is yes
they were in kind of like a Dugout canoe
right they were in areas that had not
seen human beings for forever so what
made that so dangerous what was that was
so dangerous but that particular
assignment there's no Health Care there
was nothing around they were charged by
hippos and almost crushed there were
elephants around them there were cracks
in the water yeah what do you put in the
kit for elephant elephant charging
what's what's the elephant charging like
treatment that's when you rely on the
expertise of our of our group our
Travelers
they know when an elephant the way the
ears flap if and if they're angry or
just curious yeah um there was one
Dugout canoe that was flipped over by an
angry hippo and they all ran for the to
the land to just get to any kind of
safety and they made it out
yeah that's that's I've heard stories
like that that's pretty heroin
so I would imagine that you send people
to a lot of places where there's snakes
poisonous snakes yeah venomous snakes I
should say yes how do you prepare people
for that kind of stuff um okay so
recently I had a traveler going to India
to Northern India where there's really
some venomous snakes there yeah and what
they ended up doing they were traveling
with the physician and she was able to
get the anti-venom for those snakes in
India where it's manufactured and she
carried it with them because they were
incredibly remote they would not have
been able to make it out and to health
care in time but that's a physician
would you send it with like a traveler
or would you put it in the in the kit no
you can die
from the Anti-Venom from an allergic
reaction to the antiviral you really
need to have your heart and lungs
monitored and that to be given by a
professional
it may take one dose it could take 25
vials you just don't know and it really
needs to be monitored by a health care
so that's absolutely not anything that I
would do right right wow do you lose
sleep over people with snake bite
potential I mean I just wonder but
that's one of the things I think about a
lot is like getting bit by snake in the
summer somewhere out there I do I do
less sleep I will sleep I'll probably
lose sleep for a lot of things I do
that's why I have bags under my eyes
coming up we'll meet someone who's
probably caused Karen to lose a lot of
sleep biologist Brady Barr who was once
attacked by a python in a cave on a
remote island
we'll hear that story after the break
the medical suite at National Geographic
looks like a standard doctor's office
there are stethoscopes and blood
pressure cuffs an examination table with
that weird paper they make you sit on
and a full-size refrigerator filled with
vaccines so we have our Hepatitis A and
B polio tatness but next to that
refrigerator there's one thing that's
pretty unusual hanging on the wall
so I think we wanted to ask you about
this okay that's the python the bit our
traveler gosh
so basically we're holding a poster for
dangerous encounters with Brady Barr
which is the National Geographic show
and it's signed what does this say Karen
so it says thanks for keeping me in one
piece
you guys are my heroes Brady Barr yeah
so he's holding this he's first of all
he's slimy in this cave he's like in a
cave with a headlamp on he's slathered
in mud
he's holding there's a there's a
close-up of him holding open the mouth
of the snake I guess this is the python
in a really massive set of fangs you can
see how that bit into his thigh and just
ripped because the teeth it was yeah it
was something I will never forget it as
long as I left yeah that's I can see why
for years whenever I'd go to nurse
Karen's office to get a flu shot or a
new vaccine for an assignment I'd see
that poster of Brady Barr facing down
the python it says this could be you
but it also says dude this could be you
the story behind this image has grown
into something of a legend around here
so I was excited to finally get to ask
the man himself the poster child of
Python bites to tell me his version
so tell me a little bit about how you
you know start a career where you're
catching things like snakes and
alligators you know I was animal crazy
and uh ended up getting a masters and a
PhD working on alligators in the in the
Everglades so I'd go at night in an
airboat and cruise around Everglades
National Park and capture big Gators and
then pump their stomachs you give them
it's called the holes heimlich maneuver
to get them to vomit up their stomach
contents just like you give a choking
person so I'd get these big old Gators
and give them the Heimlich and
everything in their in their stomach
comes out and man it was you know it was
like Christmas every day of the week you
know seeing what's coming out of the
stomachs
um but you know I took out a lot of film
Crews everybody wanted to go out with me
and film you know what these alligators
were eating and the procedure to get
their stomach contents National
Geographic is one of them and about the
time I graduated they said hey you know
how about coming to work for us being a
resident scientist travel all over the
world being on TV and and we'll pay you
to do this and it didn't take me long to
say yeah sign me up okay so well the you
know the iconic Brady Barr image sits in
nurse Karen's examination room to this
day and it's got this picture of you
facing down a python
I want to hear from you like what's the
what happened in this in this in this
cave with this python it took place in a
cave on a small island in Indonesia uh a
cave called The Snake Palace
soon as you step into this cave man
there's one there's two there's three
there's dozens and dozens I mean for
whatever reason and the first time I got
there
and I was excited but also horrified I
mean this place is it's it's the thing a
nightmare this is just there's bats
there's scorpions roaches all over the
walls
I don't know for sure but I'm uh
assuming that this is probably a health
risk the river about guanas crawling
with maggots from from dead bats and
other animals and then you throw in
giant pythons
um oh and it's filled with poisonous gas
so yeah by the way so you Gotta Wear
poisonous horrible yeah you got to wear
poisonous gas detectors and you know
you're in the cave and this alarm will
go off and you look down and it says you
know at this level of CO2 you've got two
minutes before irreparable brain damage
occurs so I mean not only are we
fighting for our lives with all the the
animals I mean you gotta really watch
these pockets of dangerous gas and
it it's a chamber of Horrors but it's
also a very very special place for a guy
like me
okay so you you make the questionable
decision if if I can editorialize Brady
to go into this place what happens next
so we continue into this cave and man
we're finding Python's right and left
putting these things called Data loggers
and the snakes which monitor temperature
and trying to find out why they're using
this the the cave but we're also looking
for the world's largest snake we're in
the cave and it's me my cameraman and my
producer looking over my shoulder I'm
talking to the camera about something
and then I glance back forward and I see
this giant snake big snake big snake
swimming across across the river and
it's headed for a crack in the wall
I immediately camera's rolling
frantically swimming waiting
staggering through the river of bat
guano and I grabbed a snake by the tail
don't let go of him half of it gets
inside the crack and then it's just a
tug of war and I mean once we get the
snake by the tail man it is not happy it
is it is really really not happy I'm
looking I'm looking for the head and you
know I see it down in the crack and as I
say it's agitated it is it is repeatedly
striking and biting the rock wall in
this crack so we're kind of teetering
you know I'm worried I'm going to lose
my balance and and slip under the river
of back guano to never be seen again
you know I'm looking for the head okay
can you pull in whoa whoa whoa here here
comes the head here comes the head this
thing hits me I mean it hits me on the
back of the leg I mean right you know
bad on the left buttock
I scream and I'm I'm not ashamed to say
it it hurts
it's analogous to a shark attack I mean
it is a vicious bloody open wound
so I'm screaming it's pandemonium we
still have the snake I I can't remember
how long it held on to me but it finally
released man I got a bad bite to the leg
we were able to stagger towards
Shore from this guano River and actually
subdued the snake we got its head we got
it we got it safely subdued great got
him whoa we got him
so my pants were just shredded what was
little what was left of my pants there
wasn't much so I dropped my pants and uh
so now the real adventure begins you
know I'm I'm in this this horrible River
of bat poo with a gaping open wound on
the front and back of my leg we we bag
up the snake we exit the cave and
there's always a group of locals waiting
around the cave just curious you know
see what we're doing keep an eye on
things and and they see me stagger out
in my Underpants and don't know what to
think and uh tell you what it takes a
brave man to to hike a couple miles in
his underpants in front of a big crowd
of villagers with cameras rolling
finally we made it out and after several
hours made it to uh
I don't want to call it a hospital aid
station it was if you saw it you'd say
okay it's a gas station well I want to
hear how do you initiate that
conversation with Karen okay so here's
the deal Karen
I was in a cave you know she was she
didn't miss a beat she's like okay she
asked me a few questions you know how
big are the wounds how you know is it is
it is it you know into the muscle is it
how much blood have you lost you know
all these kind of important questions
and then said okay let us let us start
working on Logistics and we'll get back
to you
foreign
technically speaking the goal is to
avoid getting bitten by a snake in the
first place but you know crazy things
happen when you send people to look for
dinosaurs in the Sahara across the
Arctic on skis or Venture into the snake
Palace on Flores Island
and over her career Karen Berry has
pretty much seen it all
what is the weirdest
case that you've had like is there one
that just stands out as like the most
bizarre like I can't believe I'm
actually faced with these circumstances
this was Brady again so this is Brady
has another one oh there's like several
phrase the whole show he was like uh he
relocated a Croc that was in Africa and
it was eating the P the literally eating
them
um as they came down to wash or to to
gather their water so this is like a
problem crocodile it was a problem Croc
and Brady went down to relocate that
Croc and he trapped this Croc he caught
him captured him and relocated them and
I said when he came back Brady how did
you know that was the right Croc he said
oh Karen he said Gators don't get that
big just by eating plants oh my God and
then he showed me a picture and I
couldn't believe it wow and it was just
hilarious to hear his take about this
hilarious slash terrifying terrifying
exactly yeah so that was probably one of
the craziest darn things
um that Brady's ever done I know he lost
an index finger when he was working in
Costa Rica this is not under your watch
though he hasn't lost any fingers while
you've been his his medical consultant
no let's just put that on the record
there
what's the last thing that you tell an
Explorer before they go out in the field
um
that they're not alone out there and
we're going to make sure that they come
home safely
and that's pretty good reassuring words
to hear as you're as you're walking out
the door I'd say yeah
[Music]
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a National Geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to Nat geo.com
Explore More to subscribe
the snake that bit Brady Barr is
actually a pretty amazing creature the
reticulated python is the longest snake
species in the world they're commonly
measured at 20 feet long longer than a
giraffe is tall and that's not all when
isolated female reticulated pythons were
able to give virgin birth a phenomenon
biologists call parthenogenesis we've
included a link to the story in our show
notes
pythons aren't venomous but the Venom of
other snakes as well as ants tree frogs
cone snails and many other creatures
might just hold the key to the next
medical breakthrough
all this and more can be found in our
show notes they're right there in your
podcast app
this week's episode of overheard is
produced by Brian Gutierrez our
producers are Kyrie Douglas and Alana
Strauss
our other senior producer is Jacob
penter our senior editor is Eli Chen our
manager of audio is Carla Wills our
executive producer of audio is Devar
artalon our photo editor is Julie Howe
this podcast is a production of National
Geographic Partners Michael Tribble is
the director of integrated storytelling
Nathan lump is National Geographic's
editor-in-chief and I'm your host Peter
Gwen thanks for listening see y'all next
time
[Music]
thank you